how are you Joseph I'm good it's funny
he did the game for game 5 thing because
I have to remind myself and we come on
camera at the beginning of every game
what game it is they all run together
I'm like I make a little rhyme in my
head like game [ __ ] shut the door okay
what's tonight then I got it what's
tonight's runnin game five there's no
jobs don't kick the Beehive okay all
right
stayin alive stayin alive and games
alive well that would have been it that
would have been it if they if the Astros
had a 3-1 lead but right it's now 2-2
and and I exid you about it last night
this has a feel to me now obviously it's
not for all the marbles like in 96 but
this has a 1996 field to me the way that
the Yankees are coming back from a no 2
spot to tie the series in a manner where
they were down like Game four of that
World Series that was the first one you
called for Fox is do you have a same
vibe or am I just out of my mind
feel free to tell me no yeah I know I I
definitely feel that some of that is
brewing and there's a familiar feel to
this but I also know the team on the
other side is really good with Keuchel
and Verlander set to go so that's what
makes this so fun you know he just
walked out if John threw out his office
and he said this feels to me like 96
yeah and for Girardi who was at the end
of his career but it was the beginning
of Jeter and Rivera and Pettit and
Posada and that whole core group for him
to say that I think it carries a lot of
weight and what he said it in a funny
way said you know for the first time I'm
seeing beer fly in the stadium and I
when you when you think of those old
highlights of 96 it's like there's beer
flying out of the upper deck like
they're shots where people are so
excited they're throwing their beer up
in the air and I think this is the first
time in this newer Stadium that was open
in 2009 has been dirty like after game
is still pristine it's like a big marble
palace and it's getting dirty this week
and I think that's a
good thing for the Yankees in their fat
yeah well then I guess you're not
throwing a beer and it costs $25 right I
guess that now you know that's true its
prices are a little steeper these days
but you're already was the guy who
tripled in that game six that led to the
win and in the game five Game six of
that World Series they had to beat
Smoltz and Maddux I mean so that's an
now you've got Keuchel and Verlander
going against each other
what what a Girardi say about the
approach to Keuchel cuz it's at some
point they got to change it the way that
Keiko has been shutting them down
correct yeah he's dominated them we said
the number last night 214 plate
appearances against Yankee hitters no
home runs Allowed and this is the number
one over on hitting now obviously that's
over the last few years but this is the
number one home run hitting team in
Major League Baseball the Yankees in
2017 he said there really isn't much
different that we can do we just can't
miss his mistakes he went back and
watched a video of Game one and he said
there were pitches to hit but we missed
him and he said you know what if birds
safe at the place is the game different
what if Altuve doesn't make the play in
the fourth inning is the game different
and and as you know as well as I do we
see this year in year out doesn't matter
the team's doesn't matter the the series
history means nothing like I'll open my
note packet tonight and it'll be you
know four teams who won Game three by a
score of 6-2 to go on to win the LCS in
the World Series nobody cares I mean
tonight once the first pitch flies
through the air what K Cole's been
against the Yankees in the past doesn't
matter and what Tanaka did in Game one
which was really good just not as good
as Keuchel doesn't matter it's all
tonight and that's what makes this job
so fun is we have no idea what we're
about to see Joe Buck gonna call Game
five tonight between the Astros and the
Yankees joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show and out you hung up your NFL
microphone for the time being and
through the World Series but in terms of
the first few weeks that you've been
calling games
with Troy Aikman the best team you saw
who was the best team that you saw with
your own two eyes in the NFL so far the
season Joe / Philly but you know I
wouldn't say they're perfect but who is
and and I think it's it's kind of who's
got the least amount of flaws at this
point in the season here in 2017 if
people talk ratings I mean the games is
is nothing that good and I don't know
that the product that's out there it
seems like it's deteriorated and I don't
know if that's because tackling is not
what it once was
you know now that was that it's upper
tiers of the new collective bargaining
agreement and the tackling and the
hitting and practices it's way down and
that's the pain of the existence of so
many coaches that we talk to but I would
say Philly in the NFC that's the
conference I see the post man Denver
looked great when we had a minutes
Dallas but then you see Dallas come out
and play the way they did after that and
you wonder how good Dallas is so I don't
know I would probably say Philly in the
NFC I would have said Green Bay but man
the the injuries are obviously piling up
to the point where it's just ridiculous
again in Green Bay and when it starts
with Aaron Rodgers on the top of the
list well menu you've got major problems
so I I don't know how they rebound to
that he's the most irreplaceable guy in
the NFL yeah that's the value I mean
when you talk about Most Valuable Player
I mean that's the value and then we'll
see what Brett Hundley is going to do so
what when is the next NFL game do you
know it right now which one you're
slated to do as you're currently yeah I
had lanta at Carolina whatever that
Sunday is I think the 5th of November
Atlantic Carolina then I think we've got
Dallas Atlanta and Washington New
Orleans game and that's all that I can
remember
yeah I mean the same thing then and the
Saints have been totally reborn and it's
entirely possible by the time that you
call Atlanta and Carolina they're both
looking up at the Saints right now who
are in Green Bay
taking on Brett Huntley in his first
career start yeah could be
you know the my group with Tom Brennaman
filling in for me with Troy is going to
the 49ers and its Cowboys at 49ers and I
man I wouldn't take the 49ers lightly I
know betters getting his first start he
looked good at the end of the game last
week but that's no layup either for the
Dallas Cowboys I it's just the heart
I've never seen a year thank God I'm not
a gambler and I don't care about that
stuff but Las Vegas there have to be new
hotels going up as we speak because you
just cannot figure out the NFL right now
it's just impossible to read
and I'm Smoltz told me and could be
right could be wrong but I'll go with it
that the team that was favored the most
hasn't won in X number of weeks now I
don't know if that's true but it's the
bigger point is whether it's Pittsburgh
losing to Chicago or you know you can't
figure the Jacksonville Jaguars or
whatever it is I don't know it's just a
weird year for the NFL and god only
knows who's going to be playing in
Finney appleís some Super Bowl 50 - well
Smoltz is on undeniable with Joe Buck
one week from tonight it debuts tonight
season four of it with Alex Rodriguez I
don't want to I don't want to give away
too much of the store of what's gonna be
tonight but can you tell me what what
what epiphany finally came over Alex
Rodriguez for him to turn the page from
denial to acceptance of what he did with
peds and then completely rehabilitate
his image when not only with the Yankees
but sports fans mostly Joe yeah I can't
I tell ya I don't know what's going on
inside his head other than I think
enough time has passed I think him being
now a member of the media certainly
helps him kind of get the bigger picture
and what options did he have you know I
think at some point you have to own up
to what you've done and I think what he
is finding
is what I think you and I both believe
that if you're honest and you say I
messed up or you know I'm sorry for what
I did
for the most part people just move on
and and I think maybe that's I would I
would imagine that's got to be really
screaming for somebody like Alex
Rodriguez he's in the next chapter of
his life he's you know he's on shark
tank he's on our pregame show he's all
over the place things that deal with ABC
News he's dating Jennifer Lopez who is
by the way an unbelievably nice woman
as I've seen firsthand but I just think
he's kind of moved on and he's willing
to let the guard down a little bit now
he's very well coached and I think the
beauty of the show that we get to do is
it's not you're not going to get that
out of them if you sat down with him for
15 minutes but after we built the story
of how he grew up and his father and you
know was the bouncing between New York
and in the Dominican Republic and
Florida and the way he died I think he
trusted us to do it the right way and
not chop up his words to misrepresent
what he was saying so he was very open
after a while you know it took I think
we sat with him for two and a half hours
and by the time you get to the end of
two and a half hours it's like Stockholm
Syndrome
I think they there's like they fall in
love with their captor and they're
willing to like basically hypnosis where
they eventually will talk and I think he
said some things that he's never said
before and I know from the text that he
and I have had going back and forth that
his friends and family have really
appreciated him doing it and he's
getting a lot of good feedback from the
early cut that he saw so good for him
it's got to feel good after all that and
right back at you with another season of
undeniable with Joe Buck tonight at 8:00
Eastern and Pacific on on audience and
before I let you go I mean it's always
you know when you when you do interview
people for a living and you do
count stories in real time for living as
you do Joe being on the other side of
the Q&A sometimes a little out-of-body
what was it like being on that other end
of the microphone if you will with one
of the greatest interviewers of all time
even though he doesn't get much credit
for that in Howard Stern you were on the
stern show a couple weeks ago yeah yeah
anybody I think who's the fan of that
show realizes how talented of an
interviewer he is and what I noticed and
I took I've done it twice now what I
noticed after after I did it the first
time is how important the face is that's
looking back at you when you're opening
up and I think you know I was really
intimidated to walk in there Monday
before the Super Bowl again
bless so this time but he's got a way of
really making you believe whether he is
or not that he's interested in what you
have to say and and that was the part
that I think and I think that's his
secret he is really engaged facially and
and I felt comfortable just kind of
loosening up and talking about things
that I would never talk about yeah
publicly and then I did with Michelle
this last time around so I there's the
secret sauce and you're very good at
this too is really being invested in the
interview I've done interviews on
late-night shows where the host is
looking over my shoulder at a producer
or thinking about the next funny line
they're going to come back with and it
was just an it was just a conversation
if as if we were in a bar talking and
that that's that's a pretty unique
feeling and setting to to foster what
she does he's great at that can you tell
me that last part again I wasn't paying
attention I love you Joe by the way when
did you start bitmoji you through a
couple of those at me the last couple
days when did you start that whenever
they first came out I saw one of my
daughter's first of all it was too corny
for my older daughter and then she then
she got into it but yeah my mine is
balding with dr. die come on and you
like Urlacher compared to if i had one
of them okay well Urlacher now looks
like I don't know what Dione tau prime
Prime's got that thing - he's got that
work and also daddy yeah he does yeah
he's got the he's bald right yeah
Rudd's bald to use the Costanza phrase
was bald not anymore
oh oh not anymore hey well I'm not
throwing stones I admitted in my book I
know I got hair plugs for days man Joe
take care I love look look forward to
listening to your call and certainly
tonight undeniable Joe Buck alright
thank you
that's at buck on Twitter the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience